[Musica]
buonasera stamattina era una bella
giornata
e allora ho deciso di fare un'escursione
ho preso gli scarponi
ho preso il mio binocolo la mia macchina
fotografica e sono uscito di casa e mi
sono imbattuto subito in questa
bellissima foresta guardate come verde
lussureggiante fitta no guardatela bene
in realtà mi sto prendendo in giro
questa una scherzo questa non è una
foresta questo è muschio però il muschio
può essere esplorato può essere
esplorato in una maniera un po diversa e
quindi andiamo a vedere più da vicino e
vediamo che ci sono tante piccole
piantine tutte ricoperte di un sottile
strato d'acqua che serve a farlo vivere
bene per esplorare questo bosco in
miniatura non si utilizza il binocolo
non si utilizza la macchina fotografica
si utilizza un altro strumento
ora non so quanti di voi avessero da
bambini un microscopio di questo tipo
io essendo molto curioso ovviamente ne
avevo uno anzi più di uno e lo
utilizzavo per scoprire mondi
meravigliosi mondi assolutamente
sconosciuti e mai visti prima bastavano
poche decine di ingrandimenti e già si
vedevano cose assolutamente meravigliose
e allora ho deciso di esplorare questo
bosco di muschio e la prima cosa che ho
incontrata è stato lui
questo è un tardigrado questo è un
animale straordinario un po perché
assolutamente indistruttibile resiste
alle più alte temperature
sopravvive a oltre 150 gradi sopravvive
a meno 200 gradi centigradi e persino in
laboratorio è stato portato a meno 272,8
gradi centigradi
quindi a meno di un grado dello zero
assoluto ed è sopravvissuto sopravvive
sulle vette delle alte montagne sulle
profondità marine ed è stato portato
nello spazio e nello spazio aperto è
stato portato non nello spazio al como
dove dentro una cabina
non ho proprio esposto alle radiazioni
solari ed è sopravvissuto e la cosa
straordinaria del tar di grado e che
ovunque intorno a noi basta una goccia
d'acqua per trovato equa eravamo a poche
decine di ingrandimenti sempre poche
decine di ingrandimenti ho trovato
questo altro animale molto interessante
questo è uno tifero vive filtrando
l'acqua intorno a sé la cosa
straordinaria che lui stesso crea la
corrente d'acqua che poi filtra con
quelle strutture particolari vicino alla
sua bocca e anche questo non è raro lo
trovate anche lui dentro al muschio
molto facilmente basta una goccia
d'acqua e poi le alghe questa struttura
bellissima meravigliosa
si chiama vol box questa è una colonia
di alghe unicellulari ognuno di quei
puntini che forma la struttura sferica e
una singola haga è un po tutte insieme
come in un formicaio in un termitaio
collaborano tra di loro per il bene
della comunità e al suo interno vedete
ci sono delle sfere più piccole verdi
che sono le colonie figlie le alghe sono
importanti sono importanti tutti quegli
organismi che fanno la fotosintesi nelle
acque il cosiddetto fitoplancton sono i
principali produttori di ossigeno sulla
terra quindi quando noi ascoltiamo al
telegiornale o sulle riviste sentiamo
che il polmone verde della terra
sarebbero le grandi foreste tropicali
non è del tutto vero perché la
produzione principale di ossigeno sulla
terra viene fatta da questi
microrganismi questo forse significa che
dobbiamo totalmente disinteressarci
dall'amazzonia preoccuparci dei nostri
mari assolutamente no
dobbiamo preoccuparci di entrambi
ma questa microscopia di base si può
applicare anche all'essere umano
e allora arrivavo col mio microscopio ad
alcune centinaia di ingrandimenti ho
deciso di sperimentare su me stesso le
potenzialità del mio microscopio non
fate questo esperimento a casa a meno
che non siate molto ma molto curiosi ho
preso un ago pungidito di quelli
sterilizzati in sterili e mi sono bucato
il dito e con quella piccolissima goccia
di sangue
ho fatto un vetrino da microscopio
preparato che ho messo nel mio
microscopio da osservare
ed ecco che cosa ho visto sì questo è
proprio il mio sangue
il mio sangue fresco e appena prelevato
dal dito si possono fare alcune
osservazioni interessanti sul sangue
innanzitutto ci sono malattie che si
possono diagnosticare immediatamente
come l'anemia falciforme in cui i
globuli rossi hanno la forma di un
falcetto e per fortuna non ho questa
malattia
questo non è il mio sangue ma come
vedete già a pochi ingrandimenti in più
siamo sempre sulle poche centinaia di
ingrandimenti si possono vedere dei
parassiti
questo è tripanosoma il vettore della
malattia del sonno che è molto diffusa
in ambienti tropicali e un altro
parassita del sangue che si può vedere a
così pochi ingrandimenti e il plasmodio
il vettore della malaria una delle più
gravi malattie diffuse sul nostro
pianeta
sempre a questi ingrandimenti si possono
vedere i lieviti i lieviti che
conosciamo
tecnicamente sono funghi sono funghi
microscopici che sono fondamentali per
lo sviluppo della nostra civiltà lo
siamo sempre stati i processi metabolici
di questi microrganismi liberano
anidride carbonica
questo gas va a accumularsi dentro
all'impasto creando quella che poi
diventeranno le alveolatura del pane che
così diventa morbido e perfettamente
commestibile
ma i lieviti sono fondamentali per la
nostra società soprattutto per un altro
motivo perché senza lieviti non avremo
la birra
ora vi ho fatto vedere queste immagini
questa mia esplorazione nel micro mondo
ma perché avevo fatto vedere lo fate
vedere perché noi abbiamo un progetto
abbiamo un progetto che vuole portare il
microscopio ovunque nel mondo e abbiamo
utilizzato un microscopio per fare
queste immagini che un pochino diverso
da quello che avevo fatto vedere
all'inizio allora qui abbiamo un tablet
potrebbe essere benissimo un telefono
con una piccola lente aggiuntiva abbiamo
un supporto per il vetrino un vetrino da
osservare una lucina
abbiamo ricostruito un vero e proprio
microscopio ottico utilizzando un tablet
queste lenti sono adesive sembrano usa e
getta in realtà non lo sono sono
durevoli si possono utilizzare per
decine o centinaia di volte senza
problemi e abbiamo creato questo sistema
di lenti che migliorano amplificano le
capacità ottiche dei telefoni dei tablet
nel 2016 con una campagna di crowd
funding in cui credevamo di vendere
alcune centinaia di lenti e alla fine ne
abbiamo vendute circa 10.000 in ogni
parte del mondo
da lì in poi abbiamo cominciato a
sviluppare altri progetti e si va dalla
fotografia macro in cui si fotografano a
mano libera fiori insetti piccoli
oggetti fino alla microscopia vera e
propria i nostri sistemi più avanzati
adesso permettono di raggiungere una
definizione che al di sotto del
millesimo di millimetro circa 1000
ingrandimenti ottici sullo schermo di un
telefono
non pensate che queste lenti vengano
fabbricate in qualche grande fabbrica in
giro per il mondo
tutti i nostri sistemi ottici sono
realizzati nei nostri laboratori qui a
genova le lenti vengono fatte una ad una
utilizzando degli stampi particolari e
utilizzando una resina uv ultra
trasparente ogni singola lente viene poi
messa dentro un bromografo dove
l'esposizione ai raggi uv e l'afa
polimerizzare quindi diventa solida
mantenendo le sue caratteristiche
ottiche le lenti vengono poi controllate
una ad una
per avere la massima qualità possibile e
garantire una perfetta nitidezza delle
immagini con lo sviluppo dei nuovi
prodotti dei nostri nuovi sistemi
abbiamo portato all'estremo la
portabilità del microscopio questo che
cosa vuol dire che noi sfruttiamo una
tecnologia che già esiste che è quella
del telefono del tablet che estremamente
portabile e aggiungiamo tutto quello che
serve per renderlo un microscopio ed
anche quello è totalmente trasportabile
e quindi quando all'inizio vi dicevo che
ho voluto esplorare una foresta fuori da
casa mia una foresta di muschio non vi
stava mentendo
questo è esattamente quello che ho fatto
sono uscito di casa e col mio
microscopio portatile ha osservato il
micromondo per se pensate alle
implicazioni di questo sistema a che
applicazioni potrebbe avere in campo
umanitario
a me viene da pensare ai agli ospedali
da campo
o anche a tutti quei posti in cui serve
un microscopio e si lontani decine o
centinaia di chilometri dal più vicino
laboratorio un sistema del genere
utilizzando un telefono che ormai si
trova in ogni angolo del globo
potremmo fornire a basso costo dei
microscopi potenti e utili per fare
delle prime diagnosi o dei pre screening
di patologie gravi che magari vanno
diagnosticate subito ma noi più in
piccolo abbiamo già fatto qualcosa
abbiamo cercato di diffondere il più
possibile la cultura del microscopio e
l'abbiamo fatto portando i nostri
sistemi nelle scuole nelle università e
anche in tutti i festival scientifici
d'italia collaboratori che fanno vedere
le bellezze del micromondo a ogni fascia
d'età
e soprattutto è questo il nostro vanto
più grande
abbiamo creato una vera e propria
community adesso hanno 2021
abbiamo venduto qualcosa come 80.000
sistemi ottici in circa 100 nazioni del
mondo e tutti questi utenti condividono
sui social foto e video di fiori insetti
vetrini preparati con tessuti o altri
campioni oggetti di piccola taglia ragni
veramente di tutto c'è un meraviglioso
micromondo che aspetta solo di essere
esplorato e basta veramente una goccia
d'acqua grazie
[Applauso]